happy birthday to take it away amanda
no i'm fine
oh come on it's sarah's birthday let's
hear you sang
sing sing
six come on beyonce
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway who wants some cake yeah yes
it's not easy being the minority in any
situation but in the workplace as the
only black woman it can be a very
frustrating and stressful environment
okay beyonce
now let's get information for this kick
i'm just in the middle of something i'll
be there in a sec
oh
and that my friend is an example of a
microaggression yeah so what is a
microaggression
brief commonplace daily verbal
behavioral or environmental indignities
whether intentional or unintentional
that communicate hostile derogatory or
negative prejudicial slights and insults
towards any group particularly
culturally marginalized groups
that's right
i've read up on this
it felt so good to be able to label that
behavior to give a name to the
underlying stress and discomfort that
comes from being confronted by
microaggressions
he means well but that's what makes
these aggressions well
micro intent is not the same as impact
and a throwaway comment or joke can have
a huge impact on the rest of someone's
day
i spoke to some friends about their
experiences in the workplace
how does it make you feel so we talked a
lot about like these microaggressions
out and out racism like in the workplace
how does that make you feel um i know
that i definitely feel
kind of other very separate to an extent
that i don't talk about any
kind of black experiences i have outside
of work some of the things that i don't
like are those sweeping statements has
anybody got an umbrella debbie will have
one because black people
don't like to get caught
right and here is the kitchen where we
really get things cooking
but seriously guys this space is used by
everyone so just be mindful about strong
spending food
right up
next photocopiers
i'm always like super polite super kind
people called you everyone's like oh
she's super friendly
but
sometimes i do just wanna like
snap back at somebody all get annoyed
and i feel like i can't i feel like the
second i
display
passion for doing a good job
people are like whoa whoa whoa whoa that
was great amanda i'm not sure the
figures are quite accurate though
actually i double checked them with
finance to make sure and they're spot on
whoa girlfriend maybe dial down the sass
a little
uh for a lot of my white colleagues
they're quite happy to just have all
these discussions about racism but
because it doesn't affect them
emotionally whereas for me it's quite
difficult to hear those conversations
because it's like i've lived through a
lot of that and i i'm just trying to do
my work and you're bringing up these
really difficult issues for me oh amanda
thank god explain to sarah what the
black lives matter movement is
all jokes aside it can be very difficult
when you find yourself on the receiving
end of this kind of behavior
so what can you do about it
well i have a few ideas
firstly
set up the situation
kate you know when you took us on that
tour the other day
next objectively describe the behavior
and get clarification you asked me to
explain the black lives matter movement
why did you ask me
next and this is the most important bit
explain the impact
if you want the behavior to stop people
need to know why john when you use
phrases like whoa girlfriend or describe
me as sassy it feels like you're
accusing me of being aggressive and
makes me worry about showing my opinions
but i haven't seen you do this to any
other members of the team
final step
do
differently
work together to come up with solutions
to ensure that you do things differently
in future
to be completely honest i hate singing
on my own and i don't think it's fair to
put someone on the spot like that
but self-selected solos from now on
it's not always going to be that easy
but hopefully these tips will provide
some helpful navigation through
difficult situations
and if things don't improve or if you
don't feel comfortable confronting a
colleague talk to your boss hr or union
rep
racial discrimination at work is illegal
it's everyone's responsibility to think
about the impact that their words might
have on someone else
now if you don't mind
i've got a party to get back to
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video